it's officially summer for students in
clark county school district
so we have a full week of activities to
explore
over the next couple of months bianca
holman is live
at a local art studio showing us lots of
fun ideas good morning bianca
hey good morning sherry you know this
isn't like other art studios this is
just
for kids and kids at heart i'm looking
at this play-doh and parents i know
you're sick of this getting stuck in the
carpet right
have them come here and play with it
we're at myanmar art studio
here in the southwest part of the valley
and this is chelsea bailey the owner
uh who's actually made slime parents you
probably made a ton of this stuff
but you haven't made it here chelsea
tell us
again all the hands-on activities that
you have i know we got slime what else
do you have to me
we have slime we also let them customize
their slime so they can do whatever
color they want
we have the pretend snow we have orbeez
they can play in
um just and we always change it up too
so we always have kind of a different
array of things for sure and also we can
customize it so you know what
i'm going to add in orange
and squirt that on in there and we're
going to make there we go add some color
and then i can add glitter right yep i
can add some glitter we're going to add
a little bit of glitter
boom that looks good nice and vibrant
and also
tell us the cleanup parents they
probably love this when their kids are
here
interacting with these activities yes
they love that they don't have to clean
up but
us moms are so used to cleaning up that
most of them do kind of
really clean up hey i'll do this i'll do
this
um but what else you know that you see
the benefit of this you know art
teachers they know
if you're a music teacher you know how
much kids need creative things and
creative outlets
what's the benefit that you've been
seeing when families come in um just
that they bond
a lot easier and just have a really good
time together and that everybody just
sleeps really happy and
enjoys themselves all right well i know
you're closed today i know it's a
holiday probably people are like oh
i can come here today yeah we are close
today we're open tuesday through
sunday though okay 11 to 7. all right
perfect so again we'll have more
about me and more art studio coming up
in the six o'clock hour
and you guys i'm gonna let you a little
hint there's a canvas back there and we
get to get it messy
send it back to you guys in the studio
wait so glitter
glitter slime is not messy it seems like
that already
already got the messy quotient locked in
it's more messy than this
john it's more messy than this fair
enough i'm looking forward to that very
good
thanks bianca appreciate that more
glitter on there more oh my goodness yes
that's gonna look great in the house
thanks bianca